so this time around amd says that things
are different the 6700 xt will be
available to purchase
the 479 dollar price tag is real
and it delivers exceptional gaming
performance at 1440p
and while i can't comment on those first
two points we can at least take a look
at how this performs versus the 3060 ti
and 3070
to see whether this is worth kind of
considering in the first place
so is the 6700 xt actually worth
considering and spending mental energy
over
let's take a look
[Music]
so on the surface really great looking
card this is the first
dual fan radeon 6000 cooler design that
we've seen which
isn't too different from the and 6800 xt
just instead of that middle fan now we
get a nice big team rocket logo
also pretty much the same size as the
reference rx 6800
two slots thick 267 mils long but the
6700 xt is 10 millimeters shorter in
terms of height
in terms of specs though just how cut
down is it versus the 6800 and 6800 xt
the answer is by quite a big chunk the
6700xc has just
two-thirds of the compute units of the
6800 although claims to operate at a
much faster boost clock out of the box
now over 2500 megahertz
the video memory has also been dropped
from 16 gigabytes to 12 gigabytes but
the cut that's really going to hurt
performance is the smaller memory
interface
now just 192 bit that results in a much
lower peak bandwidth
so honestly some pretty big reductions
here overall the real battle though is
of course against the 3060 ti
and 3070 and those are the primary
comparisons that we'll be making today
when we take a look at the benchmarks
now i'm not going to spend too long on
the pricing and kind of discussing that
throughout this review because as we've
seen with most of the gpu launches today
pricing is just completely out of this
world for most of the listings out there
even if you can find one in stock so
this is supposed to be a 480
gpu only time will tell if it actually
launches at that price and if it's
actually available
but for now let's take a look at what
kind of performance you can expect
firstly the cut down in compute units is
real versus the rx 6800 and in rainbow
six siege here at 4k
it was 20 slower on average although for
a 33
reduction in streaming processors and
compute units along with the lower
memory bandwidth you'd expect that
difference to be
a lot more so far it looks like some of
that performance is clawed back thanks
to the higher clock speeds we're still
talking about
excellent performance though the 6700 xt
is around 30
faster here than the 5700 xt but at
least in this game
it's barely faster than a 3060 ti as
typical with radeon gpus
1440p performance is a lot more
favorable than 4k
and that's exactly what we see here now
the 6700 xt is a lot closer to 3070
performance so although the rx 6800 was
aimed to be the competitor to the rtx
it looks like the rx 6700 xt fits that
suit a lot better
in terms of msrp it's 480 versus 500
with really close performance between
them again that price comparison could
be completely thrown out the window
given today's gpu market
in red dead redemption 2 the 30 70 was
around 2
faster at 1440p so basically equal but
at 4k the 3070 is about 7 percent faster
you'll see the scaling in pretty much
every game out there so if you are
weighing up between these two cards
also consider your targeted resolution
and if you are having trouble getting
your hands on a new gpu
do consider the used market as well
although that's being pretty difficult
also but if the opportunity does arise
to pick up a gtx 1080 ti on the cheap
don't be too quick to say no as for the
6700 xt and the 3070 they're pretty
close here in death stranding at 4k
73 fps versus 70 and that gap closes to
make them pretty much even at 1440p
and just as we saw a 20 difference
between the 6700 xt and the 6800 in
rainbow six we see about that same gap
here in shadow of the tomb raider
overall that huge cut down in silicon
doesn't seem to be having a massive
impact on the 6700 xt at least not on
paper
definitely not a 35 plus difference that
you'd expect
then versus the 30 70 we're looking at
about even performance at 1440p
with the 3070 taking a slight lead at 4k
so just as the msrp of the 6700 xt slots
right between the rtx 3060 ti and 3070
that's pretty much where the gaming
performance falls as well
most of the time although a bit closer
to the 30 70.
there are a few amd optimized games out
there where it'll even beat the rtx 3070
by a nice chunk
especially if we're talking about 1440p
but for the most part the 3070 is the
faster gpu but that's not even factoring
in how far ahead nvidia is
in other aspects such as ray tracing
dlss and the nvinc encoder for streaming
those are features that many would
happily pay a bit extra for
even if regular gaming performance was
about even so i'm not going to pretend
that it's a one-to-one comparison
across 10 games at 1440p the 3070 is
clearly the faster card in a few of
these titles
then they're about even in a few more
and in a couple amd optimized games the
6700 xt takes the lead
here's how that looks in terms of the
percentage gained by the 30 70. in most
cases you're looking at about a 5
or so lead and again that would increase
quite a bit at 4k
where the 3070 typically does a bit
better as for production workloads this
is another area where amd is lagging
behind nvidia quite a bit
stuck with opencl compute the 6700xt is
slower than a 3060 in blender when
rendering a 4k
image and when we factor in nvidia's
optics render times over twice as long
as a 3070. when it comes to video
editing
the huge cut down in compute units again
means performance here isn't that great
just a little bit faster than a 3060
when stabilizing a 6k
video clip as for thermals the dual fan
cooler seems perfectly adequate for the
230 watt board power
with the average gpu temp settling in at
76 degrees c
the hotspot for the memory and gpu are
also well within check
this was with the fan speed set to order
which landed at around 1650 rpm
here's an idea of what that sounds like
so in the end the radeon 6700 xt is
really
a great gpu really good performance here
for the 480
but i just can't comment on pricing and
availability which is kind of the main
point here it's kind of the big factor
which kind of makes this worth it or not
right
i have no idea if amd have produced
enough of these to the point where you
can actually buy one
and i have no idea what's going to
happen with amd's board partners
and if we're going to have you know a
repeat of the 6800 and 6800 xt launch
where the board partners just decide to
charge you know 300
over msrp pretty much all amd needs to
do at this point is produce enough and
actually sell at msrp and they win
because
buying a 3060 ti at 400 or 30 70 at
msrp 500 us it's pretty much impossible
actually it is impossible in some
regions
but on paper at least i do think the 30
60 ti and 30 70 are the better cards so
if they do kind of end up being priced
similar to the 6700 xt
those are probably the ones that i would
go for especially due to everything else
that they can do
like dlss ray tracing and you know
streaming on the nvec encoder they are
also the better option for content
creation
tasks and production workloads if you do
those so that's about all i can add at
this point i think the rest is up to amd
to actually produce this thing
and lock down that price if you're
interested i will have this linked down
below as always
a huge thanks for watching and i'll see
you all in the next one